i think visual analogies
and motion is a fundamental building
block
of the mind and you you actually see it
reflected in language
like language is full of special
metaphors
and when you think about things i
consider myself
very much as a visual thinker you you
often express your thoughts um by using
things like uh visualizing concepts
um in in 2d space or like you
solve problems by imagining imagining
yourself
navigating a concept space i don't know
if you have this sort of experience
you said visualizing concept space so
like so i certainly think about
i certainly met i certainly visualize
mathematical concepts
but you mean like in concept space
visually you're embedding ideas into
some into a three-dimensional space you
can explore with your mind essentially
yeah 2d you're a flatlander
you're um okay no
i i i do not i always have to uh
before i jump from concept to concept i
have to put it back down
on paper it has to be on paper i can
only travel
on 2d paper not inside my mind
you're able to move inside your mind but
even if you're writing
like a paper for instance don't you have
like a special representation of your
paper
like you you visualize where ideas lie
topologically in relationship to other
ideas
kind of like a subway map of the ideas
in your paper
yeah that's true i mean there there is
uh
in papers i don't know about you but
there feels like there's a destination
um there's a there's a key
idea that you want to arrive at and a
lot of it is in
in the fog and you're trying to kind of
it's almost like um
what's that called when um you do a path
planning search from both directions
from the start and from the end
but and then you find you do like
shortest path but like
uh you know in game playing you do this
with like a star
from both sides when you see where to
join
yeah so you kind of do at least for me i
think like
first of all just exploring from the
start from like uh
first principles what do i know what can
i
start proving from that right and then
from the destination
if i you start backtracking like
if if i want to show some kind of sets
of ideas
what would it take to show them and you
kind of backtrack but like yeah i don't
think i'm doing all that in my mind
though like i'm putting it down on paper
do you use mind maps to organize your
ideas no yeah i like mind maps
let's get into this because it's i've
been so jealous of people i haven't
really tried it i've been jealous of
people that seem to like they get like
this fire of passion in their eyes
because everything starts making sense
it's like uh tom cruise in the movie was
like moving stuff around
some of the most brilliant people i know
use mind maps i haven't tried really
can you explain what the hell a mind map
is
i guess mind map is a way to make
connected mess inside your mind
to just put it on paper so that you gain
more control over it
it's the way to organize things on paper
and
as as kind of like a consequence for
organizing things on paper it started
being more organized inside
inside your own mind what does that look
like you put
like do you have an example like what do
you what do you what's the first thing
you write on paper
what's the second thing you write i mean
typically uh you
you draw a mind map to organize the way
you think
about the topic so you would start by
writing down
like the the key concept about that
topic like you would write
intelligence or something and then you
would start adding
uh associative connections like what do
you think about when you think about
intelligence what do you think are the
key elements of intelligence so maybe
you would have language for instance
instead of motion
and so you would start drawing notes
with these things and then you would see
what do you think about when you think
about motion
and so on and you would go like that
like a tree it's a
tree or a tree mostly there's a graph
too like
a tree oh it's it's more of a graph than
a tree and
um and it's not limited to just you know
writing down
words you can also draw things
and it's not it's not supposed to be
purely hierarchical
right like you can um the point is that
you can start once once you start
writing it down you can start
reorganizing it so that it makes more
sense so that it's
connected in a more effective way see
but i'm so
ocd that you just mentioned intelligence
and language emotion
i would start becoming paranoid that the
categorization isn't perfect
like that i would become paralyzed
with the mind map that like this may not
be
so like the even though you're just
doing associative kind of
connections there's an implied hierarchy
that's emerging
and i will start becoming paranoid
that's not the proper hierarchy
so you're not just one way to see mind
maps is you're putting
thoughts on paper it's like a
stream of consciousness but then you can
also start getting paranoid well
if this is the right hierarchy sure like
which
it's a mind map it's your mind map
you're free to draw anything you want
you're free to draw any connection you
want and you can
just make a different mind might be if
you think the central node is not the
right node
yeah so i suppose there's a fear of
being wrong
if if you want to if you want to
organize your ideas by
writing down what you think which i
think is is very effective like
how do you know what you think about
something if you don't write it down
right uh if you do that the thing is
that it imposes
a much more uh syntactic structure over
your ideas
which is not required with mind map so
mind map is kind of like a lower level
more freehand way of organizing your
thoughts
and once you've drawn it then you can
start
uh actually voicing your thoughts in
terms of you know paragraphs
it's a two-dimensional aspect of layout
too right
yeah and it's it's a kind of flower i
guess
you start there's usually you want to
start with a central concept
yes typically it ends up more like a
subway map so it ends up more like a
graph
a topological graph without a root note
yeah
so like in a subway map there are some
nodes that are more connected than
others and there are some nodes that are
more important than others
right so there are destinations but
it's it's not going to be purely like a
tree for instance
yeah it's fascinating to think that if
there's something to that about our
about the way our mind thinks by the way
i just kind of remembered
obvious thing that i have probably
thousands of documents in google doc
at this point that bullet point lists
uh which is you can probably map a mine
map to a bullet point list
it's the same it's a no it's not it's a
tree
it's a tree yeah so i create trees but
also they don't have the visual element
like um i guess i'm comfortable with the
structure it feels like
it the narrowness the constraints feel
more comforting
if you have thousands of documents with
your own
thoughts in google docs why don't you
write
uh some kind of search engine like maybe
a mind map
um a piece of software mind mapping
software where you write down a concept
and then it gives you sentences or
paragraphs
from your thousand google docs document
that match this concept
the problem is it's so deeply unlike
mind maps
it's so deeply rooted in natural
language
so it's not um
it's not semantically searchable i would
say
because the categories are very you kind
of mention intelligence
language and motion they're very strong
semantic like it feels like the mind map
forces you to be
semantically clear and specific the
bullet points list i have
are are sparse desperate
thoughts that
poetically represent a category
like motion as opposed to saying motion
so unfortunately that's the same problem
with the internet that's why the idea of
semantic web is difficult to get
it's uh most language on the internet is
a giant mess
of natural language that's hard to
interpret
which so do you think do you think
there's something to mind maps
as um you actually originally brought up
as we were talking about
kind of cognition and language do you
think there's something to mind maps
about how our brain actually
deals like think reasons about things
it's possible i think it's reasonable to
assume that there is
some level of topological processing in
the brain that the brain
is very associative in nature
and i also believe that
a topological space is a better medium
to encode thoughts than a geometric
space then
so i think what's the difference in
topological and geometric space
well um if you're talking about
topologies
then points are either connected or not
so the topology is more like a subway
map
and geometry is when you're interested
in the distance between things and in
subway maps you don't really have the
concept of distance you only have the
concept of whether there is a train
going from station a
to station b and
what we do in deep learning is that we
are we're actually dealing with uh
geometric spaces we are dealing with
concept vectors
word vectors uh that have a distance
between the the gist expressed
in terms of dot product um we are not
we are not really building topological
models usually
i think you're absolutely right like
distance is uh
a fundamental importance in deep
learning i mean
it's the continuous aspect of it yes
because everything is a vector and
everything has to be a vector because
everything has to be differentiable
if your space is discrete it's no longer
differentiable you cannot do deep
learning in it anymore
well you could but you could only do it
by embedding it in
a bigger continuous space so if you do
a topology in the in the context of deep
learning you have to do it by embedding
your topology in a geometry right yeah
you